ouvert dans cette affaire l'objectif est
double pour emmanuel macron d'une part
un objectif politique celui de corriger
son image de président des riches mais
aussi économique bien sûr avec l'idée de
trouver de quoi compenser les 11
milliards dépensés pour les gilet jaune
du coup pas un jour sans qu'une nouvelle
idée émerge alors soit les niches
fiscales rabotées par gérald darmanin
puis l'une des deux nouvelles tranches
de l'impôt sur le revenu hier c'est
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
qui a lancé son ballon d'essai avec
cette idée de taxation des plus values
immobilières en écoute le ministre de
l'économie
c'est une piste de travail du moment
qu'on parle bien des rayons sa résidence
principale à un niveau très élevé parce
que moi je me mets à la place des
français qui ont acheté une résidence
principale sans cent cinquante mille
deux cent mille euros
il la revendre ils font un bénéfice on
va pas taxer ce bénéfice aujourd'hui il
n'est pas soumis à l'impôt n'est pas
soumis à la taxation je pense que c'est
une bonne chose
marc landré il y avait cette promesse de
ne pas augmenter les impôts là on parle
de taxe de plus value mais c'est bien de
prélèvements qu'il s'agit au final si
vous supprimez des tac d'aider des
niches fiscales ou si vous augmentez d
un pouce on monte le parlement
obligatoire qui est très paradoxal
puisque tout ça c'est lié au mouvement
des gilets jaunes qui au départ se
plaignait d'un surcroît d'imposition
donc on va se retrouver avec la sortie
elle expliqué tout le contraire de son
origine ont forcément se déplacer palais
mais ces problèmes mais faciliterait
clair que toute façon lune
c'est peut-être la seule certitude
d'ailleurs qu'on est dans ce débat et
dont l issue de ce grand débat c'est que
les riches vont en prendre plein la tête
grosso modo il faut un bouc émissaire
non mais oui mais à priori chéri vous
savez pour françois hollande c'est à
4000 euros
pour d'autres c'est à pouzac là on à
bruno le maire qui dit qu'il faut taxer
les très grosses plus values mobilières
dans son programme présidentiel 2012
pages que personne n'a lu en 2016 il
propose est exactement inverse donc il
est pas à une reculade prêt en deux ans
selon du bord de la scène dans laquelle
il se trouve
ce n'est pas la question on a
effectivement et de gérald darmanin qui
dit qu'on va raboter 1 milliards de
niches mais lui pas pour faire des
économies il dit pour redonner en poupe
en un an pour faire des baisses d'impôts
aux classes moyennes
donc ça veut dire effectivement que là
on navigue un peu à vue tout
on y va de sa petite idée vous avez une
partie de la majorité qui disent il faut
rétablir lisf mais tout de suite recréer
un crédit d'impôt pour ceux qui rient
gré et les pme tpe d'autres qui disent
qu'il faut créer un homme d'une taxation
sur les sur l'héritage
là c est assez longue
maxime d'égailler finalement c'est des
gages à l'ailé gauche ah non quand vous
dites chasse aux riches
les riches ils ont été gâtés depuis le
début du quinquennat la réalité c'est
comme celle là et la france peut
peut-être être contente d'être le
deuxième pays sur le podium de ceux qui
ont la plus grande progression du nombre
de millionnaires
il ya l'équivalent de la ville de
bordeaux de millionnaires
supplémentaires entre 2017 et 2018 et
quand on regarde aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'achat il est 5 % les plus pauvres de
notre pays ont une baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat de l'ordre de 1% depuis
un an quand les plus riches eux ont une
augmentation minimale de les 5% de plus
de 2% donc fondamentalement les super
riches
les hyper riches ont profité et profite
du quinquennat des manières mâcon il ya
bien une constante là dedans ce qui est
assez terrible aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement face à cette réalité
alors qu'il faudrait réajuster la
politique fiscale de notre pays
on voit bien que pour ne pas toucher à
des tabous qui est qu'ils sont la
question les essais pour pas remettre en
cause des premiers arbitrages et bien on
essaye de maquiller cette orientation
qui favorise quand même les plus
privilégiés en essayant de trouver une
ou deux ans ou de dispositifs qui
viendraient montrer qu'il ya une
compensation je crains que en plus
d'abord ça ne change pas grand-chose à
la faire et que au pire et bien ça se
trompe de cible est donc ce seront
peut-être classe moyenne et non pas les
hyper riches qui seront pénalisés daniel
bilalian maxime desgagnés a commencé en
disant les riches ont été gâtés jusqu'à
présent je sais pas en tout cas quand
j'entends monsieur le maire dire que les
gens qui les français qui ont des
maisons ou des appartements de plus de 2
plus de cent mille euros sont des super
riches
si c'est ce qu'il a l'air de dire il dit
je ne taxe pas jusqu'à cent mille deux
cent mille euros mais au delà je pense
que par exemple dans une ville comme
paris
deux cent mille euros ça n'existe pas un
bon bref c'est pas ça c'est un des
aspects je veux dire mais ici ce que je
comprends moi c'est qui ce dit n'importe
quoi en ce moment d'un jour sur l'autre
veut dire pour un français moyen
c'est incompréhensible je ne sais plus
j'entends de le parler des niches
fiscales le lendemain il ya on va pas
les supprimer mais il ya une complexité
du quand vous mettez le nez dans le
temps dans le système fiscal français ya
une complexité qui vous rend
qui vous rend qui vous rend dans le je
lisais ce matin que par exemple on vient
de réduire le taux d'imposition du
gasoil domestique qui était moins cher
que le gasoil auto en termes
d'imposition rendue quand on arrive à
faire des trucs comme ça dans un pays
comment voulez vous qu'on en sort voulez
vous dire c'est beaucoup plus en plus
nous donne la parole très ciblée sur ces
sujets c'est sûr qu'on écoute parce que
vous parliez effectivement darmanin et
ces niches fiscales on va l'écouter
parce qu il l'expliquait un petit peu
c'était hier sur rmc ce qu'il avait en
tête on écoute et die frau des 10 % des
français les plus riches bénéficient de
la moitié de ces niches fiscales 14
milliards d'euros ça coûte à l'état les
niches fiscales 7 milliard pour les gens
qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent et ce que
je dis c'est pas touché telle ou telle
niche ce que j'ai dit c'est que les gens
les plus riches peut-être pour être un
peu moins et dès que les classes
moyennes roche que des gens comme moi
par exemple guy gagnon
plus de 8000 euros par mois et besoin de
la solidarité nationale pour changer
mais double vitrage je pense que la
question se pose monsieur bourdin et
atrésie blaya alors à nicher niche si on
comprend bien il ya les niches les aides
à domicile il ya la niche des aides pour
les yeux au logement et puis alors
puisque dizaines at elle nuancé ses
complexes et ont fini par 474 niche
c'est peut-être même le terme de niche
qui est pas le bon parce que l'idée
niches fiscales donne l'idée davantage
d'une donne une représentation si vous
voulez qu'ils y ait davantage à du veut
dire quand un couple de cadres moyens
travaillent tous les deux qu'ils aient
besoin d'une nounou pour aller chercher
les enfants à la maternelle qu'ils
puissent effectivement avoir un avantage
fiscal pour éviter quoi un travail au
noir parce qu'on a très bien vu que
quand on avait supprimé sa aussitôt le
travail au noir et est très vite remonté
parce que les charges sont trop lourdes
et que non mon bain on va s'y prendre
autrement
donc il y a bien des avantages fiscaux
qui peuvent parfaitement s'expliquer bon
quand on essaye de faire des économies
d'énergie et qu'on est sur une
transition écologique énergétique qu'on
dise bon allez tout ce qui est dans les
investissements importants
d'amélioration des chaudières et autres
bon ça on donne un coup de pouce mais ça
peut être limitée dans le temps
alors que ça ne l'est pas donc ce qui
est sûr si vous voulez c'est que dans
notre système fiscal
il est pour le moins opaque un cirque on
a énormément de sa difficulté à savoir
exactement qui paie quoi
et du coup ça donne l'impression qu'il y
en a qui paye
qui devrait payer qui paye pas et donc
ça c'est extrêmement mauvais 1 il est
extrêmement instable c'est vrai que ça
change quand même énormément et qu'on a
un le sentiment effectivement qu'il ya
eu peut-être même pas les 1% mais que
c'est peut-être les 0 01 % qui est
effectivement ont eu des avantages
colossaux
sans compter qu'on leur ait demandé en
contrepartie effectivement d'en faire
quelque chose soit de réinvestir dans la
recherche ou ailleurs et donc on a
vraiment le sentiment qu'il ya eu des
cadeaux c'est très très très riche et
c'est pour ça que moi je serai prudente
sur l'idée la chasse aux riches
est-ce que effectivement comme vous le
rappelez
riche il était à 4000 euros pour pour
françois hollande il va être aujourd'hui
régis bulot il est ami 1000 euros pour
darmanin voilà j'ai la chance de bien
gagner ma vie j'étais à 45 % d'impôts
par an c'est à dire je rendais la moitié
de ce que je gagnais à l'état parce que
je sais que ce sera la dernière tranche
peut-être seulement mais pas sur tout
l'ensemble de vos revenus
oui j'ai quand même pas tout à fait mais
moi aussi je suis à 45 ans oui mais je
veux dire par là que comme en tant que
salarié je n'ai pas de possibilité de
l'installer mis en irlande ni au
luxembourg on ignore par ailleurs et
donc je rends des sommes considérables à
l'état et je ne me considère pas comme
quelqu'un de riche mais quelqu'un de
aisée et qui méritait de ce salaire sans
aucun doute voilà pointe à la ligne donc
les riches ça s'arrête quand même dans
ce pays ça s'arrête un peu un peu trop
vite mais je moi je il me semble que
c'est cette question de la taxation des
riches pour reprendre le terme de notre
échange et une question est une question
importante y compris dans un moment où
une grande partie de la population
souffre de d'avoir le sentiment de payer
trop de taxes c'est que vous ne pouvez
pas demander à des gens qui sont dans
des situations précaires de pouvoir
cotiser plus quand vous allez alléger
les charges pour d'autres qui sont les
plus favorisés et pour moi et gère tout
ça or hong x est une symbolique mais
c'est important
c'est évidemment la question de la
suppression de lits ssr à partir du
moment où dans le même mouvement
vous allez taxer plus les retraités et
de l'autre côté et on m'expliquera que
ce sont pas les mêmes montants mais en
tout cas c'est ça pose un problème de
cohérence cher vous pouvez pas dire aux
gens il faut que vous cotisez plus et de
l'autre côté expliqué aux plus aisés que
eux par contre on va aller rejet alléger
leurs charges et donc je crois que le
lait la résolue a fait le président
république de laon de 50 à une
présidentielle et ça a été très bien
expliqué après on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord et se dit simplement contre
on leur donne de l'argent à ceux qui ont
une capacité à investir dans l'économie
mais savent qu on s'est investi sans
vous n'en savez rien moi non plus on
attend et on n'en sait rien je reviens
on n'a pas encore vu l'effet de la
politique
après effectivement le jour ce sera
évalué le fait qu'il n'y a pas eu le
premier tour musulmans
seulement si jamais il est démontré que
la théorie du ruissellement ne
fonctionne pas bon ce qui était revenu
en arrière ce qui est des taxes ont
éventuellement moins soudé plus aisés ce
qui est donc ce n'est pas le cas mais ce
qui est démontré aujourd'hui c'est le
cas le caractère de plus en plus
inacceptable et d'ailleurs ces
mouvements des gilet jaune de beaucoup
de personnes qui ne comprennent pas
qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi est
ce que doivent payer plus alors qu'août
d'autres doivent payer - et donc vous
vous êtes vous marquent également
viendrait ensemble un enjeu économique
milliards d'euros en pouvoir d'achat qui
est rendu au genre qui est pas rendu aux
plus riches qui est rendu alors aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
populaires ou laborieuse comme dirait le
président de la république
la concomitance que l'échangé de
passionnant question twitter que vous
pose
les mesures proposées c'est à dire
taxation des plus values immobilières
isf niches fiscales les mesures
proposées pour alourdir les impôts des
plus riches vous par estelle juste et
bah c'est extrêmement partagés 51 %
d'entre vous pensent que c'est le
mesures ne sont pas justifiées enfin
donc content de dire que c'est
moitié-moitié quelques réactions nicole
et serait utile pour tous qui nous
définissent une fois pour toutes il je
pense que manuel macron à quel niveau de
revenus on est riche
le montant change toujours en fonction
des sujets monsieur babineau complète
c'est assez drôle de voir un
gouvernement qui a allégé les impôts des
plus fortunés depuis dix ans 18 mois et
qui prétend renverser la vapeur r34
ajoute ce qu'ils payeront seront de
toute façon la classe moyenne supérieure
cadres et surtout cadre retraité
préoccupations des retraités sort la
politique actuelle va tuer le btp en
france je suppose et pour les stars 2
notamment d'isolation monsieur babineau
enfin je pense qu'après avoir fermé la
porte au rétablissement de la sf ce
gouvernement tente de bricoler au tour
daniel annonce je vais simplement dire
c'est que là encore il ya la vérité des
choses il ya des impressions
l'impression qu'on a eu cette
suppression isf augmentation de la csg
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
retraités donc après que ce soit juste
pas juste l'impression et de la banque
voilà la première a discuté et nous et
nous on prend on prend on prends moi
j'ai pris deux mille euros de moins par
an voilà une question qui est importante
macron c'est que s'ils taxe beaucoup ces
classes moyennes supérieures c'est son
électorat c'est vraiment
le coeur de son électorat qu'il faut
qu'il soit quand même aussi un peu
prudent parce qu'eux aussi ils ont voté
maquereau en pensant qu'ils vont ils ont
déjà un peu de données mais c'est sans
doute normal et patti la solidarité
depuis 2010 avec fillon quand on a
commencé à augmenter un certain nombre
d'impôts parce que ça n'a pas démarré
qu'avec au long d'un aimerait dès 2010
avec hollande largement aussi donc il a
l'impression qu'ils allaient un peu
respirer respirer et puis apparemment si
il y en a qu'on doit taxer ça va être
encore eux qui vont être taxés pour
mâcon c'est quand même prendre un
thierry salles oubliez une chose qui est
là pour le coup c'est une vérité c'est
validé par des faits la france est un
pays est un des pays où la politique de
rudy de redistribution réduit le plus
les inégalités entre les revenus et donc
j on peut se plaindre qu'on paie
beaucoup d'impôts ou que les riches ne
payent pas assez ou que les pauvres n'en
paye moi je me plains plutôt que l'ailé
des gens n'ont pas suffisamment faut
savoir quand même qu'il ya plus il ya 56
% sur le revenu revenu va de foyers
fiscaux le toupet la tva mais de l'impôt
sur le revenu je veux dire c'est là tout
le monde paye la csg
donc on peu après jugez un peu plus un
peu moins et c'est là qu'est le maroc
ceci dit d'ailleurs ce que vous dites
est vrai parce que mais le prélèvement à
la source qui est en place depuis le
premier jour il va permettre justement à
ce que tout le monde puisse payer des
impôts sur le revenu dès le première le
premier euro de gagner tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas le coût de collecte
on avait jusqu'à présent ce qui fait
aller les chercher l'impôt est plus cher
c'était plus cher d'aller collecter que
ce qu'on devait récupérer là c'est fini
maintenant comme si tout est fait par
des flux numériques jeanne ya plus de
coûts de collecte de l'impôt donc on
peut maintenant avoir un impôt sur le
revenu qui se fanent qui s'applique dès
le premier euro gagné et pas maintenant
avec une franchise qui est sur les sept
succès tous eu 1000 premiers euros
gagnés par au sujet inépuisable
on le voit vous avez par l'électorat
d'emmanuel maquereaux au vin très
ciblées on va parler des jeunes alors
c'est pas vraiment